After months of colorful
teasers and posters,
Warner Bros. has finally dropped
the first official trailer
for "Birds of Prey."
From its references to the
Joker to this adorable hyena,
here's everything you
missed in the new trailer.
The trailer begins with Harley Quinn
announcing her breakup with the Joker.
Harley: The Joker and I broke up.
Narrator: This changes
everything for Harley,
including a new haircut and
a symbolic change in attire.
"Suicide Squad" showed
Harley wearing a T-shirt
with a reference to the Joker,
while the new Harley
Quinn symbolically wears
an outfit with her name on it,
identifying her as a more
independent character.
The song that plays throughout the trailer
is Édith Piaf's "L'Hymne à l'Amour,"
or "The Hymn to Love."
It's an obviously ironic choice for a song
that exemplifies the
love-and-hate relationship
between Joker and Harley.
So, how does Harley try to move on?
By burning down a building, of course.
A shot from the trailer
shows Harley burning down
the Ace Chemicals factory,
a location that essentially created
both Joker and Harley Quinn
and was also featured
briefly in "Suicide Squad."
The same factory seems
to later be inspected by
none other than Renee Montoya,
a detective from Gotham City
who never technically was a
member of the Birds of Prey
but has had a history of
accompanying them in comics.
And, speaking of Montoya, we see some of
the other official
members of Birds of Prey.
Like Black Canary, portrayed
by Jurnee Smollett-Bell,
working as a singer at a nightclub.
And this cool shot briefly
hints at her superpower,
the "canary cry," her ability to let out
an ultrasonic scream.
The cup is shaking from her singing.
Perhaps she doesn't yet understand
the extent of her power.
We also get a better look at the Huntress,
a lethal vigilante played
by Mary Elizabeth Winstead.
The character also made an
appearance in CW's "Arrow."
And from the looks of it,
it seems like the Huntress
is already very much active,
serving justice with
her trademark crossbow.
And finally, Cassandra Cain,
an assassin who once took
the mantle of Batgirl
in the comics.
While she was always portrayed
as having difficulty with
speech, this adaptation
seems to have no trouble
bantering with Harley.
So it's safe to assume that the filmmakers
are taking the most
liberty with the character,
the film being one of her
first live-action adaptations.
And, for the first time,
we get a look at them together as a team.
The Birds of Prey.
So, what brings these
unlikely characters together?
The best guess is this man, Roman Sionis,
or Black Mask,
an infamous villain from
the "Batman" comics.
While he's a villain most well
known for his iconic mask,
we never see it in the trailer,
although it's heavily
foreshadowed throughout,
such as from these dancers in the club
or the painting behind him
during what happens to be
his psychotic breakdown.
But for now, Ewan McGregor
seems to be playing Roman Sionis
before he becomes Black Mask,
also suggested by these
initials on his gloves.
The trailer also implies that Roman has
an obsession with Harley.
We also see Harley performing
in Roman's nightclub,
a scene that is a direct homage
to Marilyn Monroe's performance in 1953's
"Gentlemen Prefer Blondes."
It's also the same nightclub
that Black Canary performs
in and meets Harley.
Perhaps the two characters bond
with their hatred for Roman
and recruit the help of others
to fight a common enemy.
And perhaps the fight
turns Roman to Black Mask.
And is that when he
hires the help of Zsasz,
another famous "Batman" villain
we get a glimpse of in the trailer?
We can only predict for now.
And, of course, it's impossible
not to talk about the hyena.
The trailer shows Harley adopting a hyena
from an exotic pet shop
and even reenacting a scene
from the "Lady and the Tramp."
This is a concept that first appeared in
"The Batman Adventures: Mad Love."
But the hyenas are more popularly known
for their appearances in
"Batman: The Animated Series."
What's odd is that there's
supposed to be two of them,
Bud and Lou, named after
the two famous comedians
Abbott and Costello.
So, where is the other one?
The hyenas aren't the only reference to
the animated series.
An outfit that Harley wears in this shot
closely resembles her attire
in the episode "Harley's Holiday,"
which also features Harley
firing a cork as a weapon,
similar to how she fires a beanbag
to knock out an officer in the film.
Fun note: You can see various items
throughout the letters of the title
that symbolize the different characters,
like this arrow that
symbolizes the Huntress;
Harley's hammer, which can be found here;
and a razor and brass knuckle
that most likely belong to Zsasz.
So, was there anything we missed?
Let us know in the comments.